歡迎收看泛科學新聞
謝謝近期加入認養泛科學
的那個阿伯的會員
在此誠摯感謝另外 100 位泛糰
我們才得以繼續嘗試
各種不同的科學傳播方式
例如日更的泛科學新聞
周更的議題正片
以及月更的慢科學
如果你希望看到我們做更多創新
探討更多主題
請務必透過加入會員
來成為泛科學火箭的助推器
如果你有絕佳點子
或是想讓自己的認真研究成果被介紹
甚至想要加入我們團隊
都非常歡迎
趕快跟我們聯繫吧
這個不得了
我們的細胞也可以裝「黑盒子」？
美國麻省理工跟哈佛博德研究所
剛發表在《Science》的新研究
做出一個叫 TimeVault 時光穹窿的系統
為什麼這茲事體大？
因為細胞本來是完全沒有記憶力的
細胞想幹嘛
全靠 mRNA 來傳令
所有的命令合起來
叫做「轉錄組」(Transcriptome)
就像玩遊戲時的所有狀態
血條剩多少、背包裝了什麼
正在打哪隻王
問題是這狀態是限時動態
事情做完幾小時內自動刪掉
事後去研究
只剩一片空白
Don't blink, you might miss it
但你想
我們拿抗癌藥對癌細胞掃射
大部分死了
一小撮活下來
去驗這一小撮
發現它們身上都有防禦裝備
例如 FN1 纖維粘連蛋白 1
這種防禦基因開超高
但我們永遠不知道一件事
它們是中槍後
像魔虛羅那樣去適應
還是中槍前就把里香叫出來擋
如果是前者叫反應快
如果是後者叫預謀
但過去我們沒有黑盒子
只能看殘骸
永遠無法重播「開槍前」
過去整個生物學
尤其是癌症研究
就卡在這個超大盲點
時光穹窿就是為此而生
科學家把腦筋動到細胞裡
一個超怪的結構
穹窿體（Vault）
這是一種存在於真核細胞中的胞器
大到可以把核糖體塞進去
外殼硬到核酸酶啃不動
長得像橡木酒桶
妙的是
它在人體內存在了幾億年
科學家到現在還是不知道它是要幹嘛的
那就拿來用吧
研究團隊設計了一個基因工程爪子
是所謂的嵌和蛋白
一端專抓 mRNA 的尾巴
另一端死死吸在穹窿體內壁
把穹窿體改造成了獄門疆
只要細胞一發 mRNA
爪子就把限時動態抓進穹窿體存起來
門一關
時間彷彿凍結
原本只能活 17 小時的 mRNA
現在可以活超過 132 個小時
這時候細胞不需要再解釋什麼
因為時光穹窿會替它說話
Don't talk too much, just listen.
但其實細菌也有類似的玩意
叫做封裝體
團隊不輕敵
拿三種細菌的小小封裝體
PK 我們的大大穹窿體
結果確認時光穹窿的捕捉效率
高出 20 倍
接著團隊把細胞打破
變成一灘「屍水」(Lysate)
然後丟在 37度C 下讓它腐爛
一般的 mRNA 幾小時就爛光
但關進時光穹窿裡的 mRNA
過了整整 12 天
拿出來定序還是讀得到
團隊還不滿意
接著對細胞進行熱休克
燒它一陣子、冷卻休息後
用傳統方法去驗
誒 驗不到痕跡
但時光穹窿這黑盒子一打開
裏頭全是 HSP 熱休克蛋白的慘叫紀錄
前面是能力驗證
最後一關才是重頭戲
他們先幫肺癌細胞錄影
然後投下標靶藥 Osimertinib
來場大滅絕
99% 的癌細胞死光
剩下一點點倖存者
團隊把它們體內的黑盒子打開看重播
發現這些傢伙在藥物還沒襲擊之前
就已經開啟了 FN1、AKR1C1
這些防彈基因了
科學家再用干擾 RNA (siRNA)
把 FN1 這些護盾打爆
再投藥
Bingo
這些原本打不死的癌細胞瞬間死透
這證明抗藥性不是練出來的
是天生的
這些癌細胞就是躲著等別人先倒下
這研究大幅拓展了細胞研究的可能
既然黑盒子可以裝到我們的細胞裡頭去
你覺得除了研究癌症
還能用來做什麼呢
要是你的細胞裡也裝了黑盒子
會發現什麼呢
蛤
已經畫成《工作細胞Black》了啊
嗯
總算
科學家突破了那個通往 AGI 的瓶頸
嘴
雖然人型機器人動作越來越靈活
但為了避免恐怖谷效應
廠商都刻意避過五官
特別是嘴
不然就跟加拿大人一樣只會上下開合
跟發出的聲音失和
蛤
你說真的加拿大人不是這樣
我被《南方公園》騙了？
怎麼可能
但在《Science Robotics》期刊的最新研究中
科學家不僅給機器人一張
有 10 個自由度 (10-DOF) 的軟Q矽膠臉皮
還讓它像現在的小孩一樣學說話
嗯
不是看爸媽
而是看 YouTube
美國哥倫比亞大學工程學院的團隊
在軟Q的矽膠皮膚底下
設計了一個有十個獨立控制點的機械結構
透過精密拉索與連桿系統
模擬環繞我們嘴唇這條
口輪匝肌的複雜運作
能張嘴、抿嘴、嘴角單邊上揚
甚至擺出那種
「不爽你咬我啊」的複雜微表情
這是它逃出恐怖谷的硬實力
但真正能讓它
Tell me what you want,
tell me what you need 的
是它的軟靈魂
「自我監督學習」
修煉過程分兩階段
第一階段叫
「馬達牙牙學語」(Motor Babbling)
機器人剛開機的時候
完全不知道拉動三號馬達會怎麼樣
它必須對著鏡子
進行好幾個小時的「顏藝」訓練
它會隨機抽動那十條臉部肌肉
一下歪嘴、一下嘟嘴
然後透過攝影機看自己的臉
紀錄每一個馬達指令對應的畫面變化
就像綠谷在鏡子前模仿歐爾麥特
重點是這個過程
完全不需要人類介入標記數據
它透過這幾千次的自我觀察
建立了一套專屬的
「視覺－動作」肌肉記憶模型
練完肌肉控制
第二階段是「跨模態翻譯」
科學家讓機器人狂看 YouTube 上
人類說話和唱歌的影片
同步發動兩個 AI 模型
首先是「變分自編碼器 (VAE)」
它能把影片中人類複雜的嘴型畫面
壓縮成一組機械可理解的精簡密碼
像是捏臉系統裡的數據代碼
接著是 FAT
臉部動作 Transformer
(Facial Action Transformer)
架構跟 ChatGPT 一樣
但它不是讀文字預測下一個字
而是讀入聲音波形
然後預測下一個嘴型
再轉換成那十顆馬達的動作指令
這有多強
當我們準備發出「把拔」的時候
嘴唇必須在聲音出來之前
先緊緊閉上集氣
對吧
傳統機器人只會等聽到「叭」的一聲才張嘴
往往慢半拍
看起來像配音配崩了的爛片
但因為 FAT
具備 Transformer 的「注意力機制」
它不只聽當下
還會分析前後語音脈絡
當 FAT 偵測到這串音訊特徵時
會提前下指令給馬達
欸 3 號跟 7 號馬達
馬上閉緊
0.1 秒後再爆開
這種精準「預判」
讓機器嘴能呈現人類說話時特有的
「共音化現象」
讓嘴型與聲音完美黏著
講白了
它不背誦單字
而是把「聲音」這種聽覺資訊
直譯成「肌肉收縮」的運動資訊
做到「端到端」學習
目前能做到 11 國語言的近乎完美對嘴
就連 チョコミント よりも Avatar 都行
不過科學家也承認
某些需要「閉嘴爆氣」的發音
像是「B」、「P」這種爆裂音
或是需要極致嘟嘴的「W」
還是有點障礙
畢竟矽膠還是不比人類肌肉那麼靈活
但很快
實體 Vtuber 的嘴型
就能完美搭配中之人的話語
甚至來個結尾妖精
是說機器人看 YouTube
就能自己學會控制嘴
那要是看
嗯
不就能學會
誒
這很無齒
好油喔
我說的是美國紐約大學的研究團隊
他們展示了一種
絕對無齒、絕對油的「流體齒輪」
研究剛剛發表在
《物理評論快報》(Physical Review Letters) 上
這有什麼用
你想
不管是愛德華的機械鎧
還是霍爾的移動城堡
只要是齒輪
宿命就是「硬碰硬」
有接觸就有磨損
有磨損就有粉塵
最後就卡死給你看
要是卡在微型機器人
或是要進入人體血管的醫療器材裡
哪有空間換機油呢
那那那
如果把齒輪原本接觸的地方
換成液體會怎樣
流體能精準傳遞動力嗎
為了驗證
研究團隊把兩根圓柱體
垂直插進充滿甘油水溶液的水箱裡
這實驗的關鍵在於
為了不讓儀器本身的摩擦力干擾數據
他們把那根負責被帶動的「被動轉子」
安裝在「空氣軸承」上
這就像是讓它浮在氣墊上一樣
摩擦力幾乎是零
只要流體輕輕一推
它就會轉動
接著馬達啟動
主動轉子開始旋轉
這時候兩根棒子之間
開始名符其實地拔河
論文稱之為「剪力競爭」
也就是「內側的水流」跟「外側的水流」
看誰力氣大
誰就能決定被動轉子往哪邊轉
一開始轉速比較慢、雷諾數低
液體很黏
這時候「內側」的推力佔上風
假設主動棒是順時針旋轉
它會把中間縫隙的液體
像擠牙膏一樣帶動
這個液體的流向會推動被動棒
讓它變成逆時針旋轉
這就是我們熟悉的「齒輪模式」
兩邊方向相反
很合理吧
但只要條件一變
物理直覺就會失效
科學家發現
有三種情況會讓「外側」的水流獲勝
形成像皮帶一樣的包圍流場
逼著兩根棒子「同向旋轉」
第一種情況是當你把轉速加快
讓雷諾數飆高超過 55 的時候
這時候液體的「慣性」衝勁戰勝了「黏性」
離心力把液體甩向外側
來個領域展開
繞一個大圈把兩根棒子包在裡面
結果被動棒就被帶著一起順時針旋轉
這叫「慣性轉型」
第二種情況叫「幾何轉型」
發生在兩根棒子靠得非常近的時候
因為中間的縫隙太窄了
液體根本擠不過去
內側的推力窒息
這時外側的流場接管了局面
結果也是順時針轉
最後一種情況叫「拓撲轉型」
發生在兩根棒子拉得非常遠的時候
中間的連結斷了
流場結構發生重組
變成兩個獨立的渦流在遠端互動
隔空牽引
結果依然是順時針旋轉
這發現可有用了
除了能隔空傳輸動力
只要改變流體齒輪的轉速或調整距離
就能直接切換正轉或反轉
而不需要複雜的機械換檔
袂落輦 bē lak-lián
雖然目前這還在實驗室的甘油箱裡演練
但這種無齒零接觸、好油沒摩擦的傳動法
未來在微型機器人
或者人體內的醫療器材裡
肯定用得上
蛤
你也想泡在甘油裡面旋轉
不對
為什麼我用「也」...
你有朋友天生紅髮嗎？
蛤
真的有啊
誰啊
她開貳號機啊
喔
記得跟她說
根據西班牙國立自然科學博物館
發表在 《PNAS Nexus》 的最新研究
科學家終於解開了她身上演化的謎團
為什麼紅髮、淺膚色、有雀斑的朋友
他們的基因會製造「褐黑素 (Pheomelanin)」
這種廢物色素
說它是廢物不過分
這褐黑素不像真黑素 (Eumelanin)
能防曬擋紫外線
反而具有促氧化特性
會釋放出活性氧類
去攻擊細胞核裡的 DNA
增加黑色素瘤 (Melanoma) 的風險
按理說這種基因早該被天擇淘汰了
為了找答案
科學家找來了一群斑胸草雀 (Zebra finches)
這種鳥的公鳥平常臉頰上有橘紅斑塊
對 那就是褐黑素
科學家開始餵牠們吃
高劑量的半胱氨酸飲食
模擬「營養過剩變有毒」的極端狀態
接著重頭戲來了
科學家對其中一組鳥
注射了一種代號 「ML349」的藥物
它是一種 APT2 (醯基蛋白硫酯酶 2) 抑制劑
而這個 APT2 原本會減弱 MC1R
這個控制毛色的產線總指揮
如果 MC1R 指揮得起勁
那就只會生產真黑素
要是被干擾
就會改做褐黑素
所以注射 ML349
就能強制把鳥體內的褐黑素產線關閉
關鍵就在這
我們早就知道褐黑素是由
「半胱氨酸 (Cysteine)」這種氨基酸合成的
雖然半胱氨酸是我們體內最強抗氧化劑
穀胱甘肽的原料
但因為含有硫基(-SH)
量太多的話
會引發一種聽起來很中二的細胞死亡反應
「雙硫死亡」(Disulfidptosis)
所以科學家懷疑
人的紅髮或鳥的橘毛
其實是為了「排毒」
結果呢
那些褐黑素產線被關閉
但又吃了一堆半胱氨酸的鳥
體內的氧化損傷指數 (MDA) 炸裂
細胞膜被自由基瘋狂攻擊
相對地
那些可以製造褐黑素的鳥
牠們把多餘的半胱氨酸全部抓起來
經過化學合成
變成了無毒的褐黑素
然後堆到羽毛上
橘紅色斑塊因此變得更紅更漂亮
抽血檢查發現細胞毫髮無傷
這就證明了褐黑素的確是一個內建的
「資源回收緩衝區」
演化保留這個基因
可能是因為當生物體內
有太多半胱氨酸的時候
身體為了不讓細胞被毒死
就透過褐黑素產線
把多餘的半胱氨酸打包、固化
做成褐黑素
塞進頭髮和羽毛裡
在某些環境壓力下
例如連續一萬年
都只有長毛象肉或野燕麥可以吃的話
這種單一飲食會讓人慢性中毒
這時候紅髮基因
因為對雙硫死亡有抗性
起碼在繁殖期
細胞比較健康
比一般人稍微多了那麼一點點優勢
因此就被保存了下來
畢竟演化並不 care
他們老了之後會不會得皮膚癌
只在乎能不能活著把小孩生下來
蛤
你要介紹你紅髮朋友給我認識
不用了
我真的有朋友是紅髮
她會騎王蟲
總算啊
「物理學界最強花瓶」的弦論
找到工作了
這項由美國壬色列理工學院 (RPI) 領軍
發表在《Nature》的研究指出
我們的血管、神經
甚至是路邊的樹
其實更像是用「弦論」的數學畫出來的
我先說
不要覺得科學家瘋了
物理學家本來就
嗯
畢竟過去一百年
生物學家跟數學家在看這些分岔結構時
都戴著「Cost down 濾鏡」
「史泰納樹 (Steiner Tree)」理論
它假設大自然為了省材料
管線一定走最短路徑
分岔一定是「二分法」
就像一個Y接著一個Y
如果看到像海神三叉戟
那樣的三叉路口
或是像違停一樣 90 度插進來的垂直分支
就會被當作演化的瑕疵
是不完美的次級品
但當大自然裡的誤差多到變常態
理論就得檢討了
這次物理學家決定對生物學
使出 “世界”
沒錯 正是弦論的「世界面 (Worldsheet)」
在傳統物理學
粒子是一個點
走過的時間軌跡是一條線
叫「世界線 (Worldline)」
以前生物學家也是這樣看血管跟神經的
把它當成原子筆畫出的細線
沒有厚度
但在弦論裡
基本單位不是點
而是「弦」
當弦在時空中移動
掃過的軌跡是連續的「曲面」
「世界面」
而真實的血管跟神經本來就不是線
是有厚度的管子
所以研究團隊把人類神經、果蠅大腦、血管、
熱帶林木、珊瑚、擬南芥等六種天差地遠
但同樣會分岔來、分岔去的生物結構
丟進電腦
用「世界面」觀點重新建模
具體來說
他們先把從生物體掃描到
原本只是細線的數據
在電腦裡「充氣」
他們設定一個參數 w (管徑)
把骨感火柴人膨成米其林輪胎人
從一維的圖結構
變成了二維的流形
接著登場的是弦論的核心公式
南部-後藤作用量 (The Nambu-Goto Action)
這公式看起來嚇人
實際上也是
但在這裡只做一件事
計算表面積
在弦論裡
世界面會因為張力自然縮到最小
跟吹泡泡一模一樣
所以科學家其實是對著血管模型下指令
假設你們全是肥皂膜
現在給我縮到最小
結果舊理論解釋不了的現象
發生了
當管子變粗、距離夠近
中間那層「數位肥皂膜」會因張力太大
啵！一聲
兩個分開的 Y 字型路口
瞬間吸在一起
融合成一個穩定的三叉路口
這在數學上叫做「拓撲相變」
不是人工畫的
是物理定律自動跑出來的
更妙的是
那個被舊理論嫌棄的 90 度垂直分支
在弦論模型裡
竟然也是能量最低的穩定態
研究團隊進一步檢查人類大腦資料
發現高達 98% 的垂直分支
末端都連著突觸
這就像是神經元為了跟鄰居借醬油
不想繞遠路
直接在牆上打個洞伸手過去
結構非常有效率
不過如果你有這種鄰居
建議還是先報警
當然生物不能只顧表面積
研究團隊畫了一張「相圖 (Phase Diagram)」
當管子很細的時候
體積限制勝出
結構就會乖乖長成普通的二叉樹
但當管子變粗
像是大腦神經主幹
弦論效應就會接手
迫使結構發生相變
長出三叉路口和垂直分支
不過這個弦論模型只描述物理限制
生物還有很多老闆要伺候
像是基因跟化學訊號等
實際型態跟弦論模型還是有差的
但你看
連弦論都找到新工作了
你還在等什麼呢
泛科學正在招募科學編輯
轉職就趁現在
等你喔
以上就是本週的泛科學新聞
如果你喜歡今天的內容
或是對哪一則新聞想黜臭
歡迎在下面留言
也別忘了按讚、訂閱、開啟小鈴鐺
下週繼續發現這世界有多荒唐
如果你有拍到什麼比 甘油裡旋轉的棒子
更好看的背景圖
歡迎投稿喔
詳情請看下方的資訊欄
我們下週見